[Applaudissements]
ça fait plus de 20 ans qui est manuel
est cuit travaillent dans le secteur
pétrolier comme entrepreneur il fournit
du matériel aux compagnies de forage
il a connu l'âge d'or de l'industrie et
des gros vos explorations qui avec vont
être annoncée bientôt les temps plus
difficiles ces dernières années aussitôt
que le dessin tout en battant mais ce
qu'il vit depuis quelques semaines c'est
du jamais vu
en soixante dix employés on est descendu
à deux ou trois employés chinois serait
que c'est en déclin avec la baisse de la
demande mondiale en pétrole la guerre de
prix entre l'arabie saoudite et la
russie
le baril vaut à peine 4 $ en alberta
même avec les subventions salariales
d'ottawa c'est impossible pour emmanuel
de rester en affaires à long terme il va
fermer boutique dans les prochaines
semaines dès que son dernier contrat est
terminé il reste plus de job c'est un
nouveau pays groupe pétrolier ça descend
ça descend à cracovie de marketing qui
vient de fermer une majorité des débits
fabrication que des chocs des usines
clairement qu'on peut faire on a quand
même un loyer à payer
et comme propriétaire d'une petite
entreprise
emmanuel n'a pas la marge de manoeuvre
des grandes pétrolières qui peut
fonctionner à perte pendant plusieurs
mois pour former une raffinerie ou
fermer des gros secteur pétrolier ça
peut prendre jusqu'à un an pour leur
parti ils feront pas ça ils vont arriver
rouler à gap pendant un certain temps
pour édith compagnie on n'a pas su nous
autres ex compagnon travail de moi mo i
sar en plus et en alberta au canada je
pense que ses rangs du point
cet expert en gestion d'énergie croit
aussi que la crise de la kfw 19 pourrait
affaiblir le secteur pétrolier à long
terme parce que les investisseurs
risquent d'être plus frileux parce que
le covin 19 montre à mon avis c'est la
fragilité du secteur avec des prix qui
peuvent chuter c'est pas un élu swiss a
acheté de manière historique mais c'est
quand même deuxième chute en six ans
parce qu'on en avait eu en 2014
et ça commence à faire très mal ils
pensent que l'alberta n'a pas le choix
diversifié son économie
emmanuel en tout cas n'a pas attendu
pour se réinventer
pendant qu'il fait une boutique d'un
côté de la rue il en ouvre une autre en
face
dans un tout autre domaine commence il
est en train de développer un système
d'agriculture verticale ou les plantes
poussent dans l'air
présentement c'est la vie et pour tout
le monde pour moi ça changera
ici laurence martin radio-canada away
taskiouine en alberta